[Musica]
sono nata in ritardo per questo corro ma
non sono la persona migliore per
parlarvi di maratone nasco il 5 febbraio
1973 allora tecnicamente la data
corretta sarebbe stato il 3 giorno in
cui si sono rotte le acque di mia mamma
ma lei facendo un patto col diavolo e
uno con la natura ha continuato le
consegne del sabato pomeriggio le
pulizie della domenica e mi è toccato
nascere il 5 come prima della mia
nascita anche dopo la mia nascita in
casa si è continuato a correre allora
mio papà correva davvero perché guidava
gli autobus poi correva dare una mano a
mamma in bottega poi correva in comune a
fare attività politica
la nonna poverina correva tutto il
giorno dietro e mio fratello e poi anche
lei dava una mano alla bottega la mamma
insomma una fatica incredibile e poi
sono gli anni settanta e mia nonna che
di guerre ne aveva vissuto e due aveva
il terrore che mancasse il cibo in
tavola per cui la pentola bolle va
voleva bolliva bolliva 24 ore al giorno
e la parola più ricorrente quando
mettevamo le gambe sotto il tavolo era
presto mangia che diventi grande un
incubo quindi capite che non sono di
sicuro cresciuta in una famiglia oziosa
a 8 anni per osmosi per gioco lavo le
scale dell'intero palazzo dove viviamo
ascensore incluso
sono stata una studentessa fuori corso
con tanti lavoretti barista commessa
cameriera durante un'estate quella dei
miei sedici anni ho venduto corsi di
inglese porta a porta il paese era
grosso così mi conoscevano tutti corsi
d'inglese venduti devo dire neanche uno
ma ho fatto una quantità di merende
incredibili poi l'ultimo lavoro prima di
quello definitivo è stato gestione e
recupero crediti per un'importante
società bancaria e ovviamente crediti
erano irrecuperabili voi potete
immaginare con le provvigioni che ho
preso dal dal lavoro che facevo non c'è
neanche pagato l'abbonamento del treno
però mio papà storico diceva ricordati
che quando io ero piccolo per andare a
bottega imparare qualcosa i genitori i
miei dovevano ancora dare qualcosa al
maestro per cui impara l'arte e mettila
da parte ragazza che fai prima
i sette anni cerco di laurearmi e arriva
il lavoro che non sogno ma che mi ha
fatta innamorare follemente e ed è stato
un bellissimo lavoro un'azienda che
sbarca in italia con un concetto
commerciale completamente nuovo sono
stati anni di vorticosa crescita di
energia
eravamo galvanizzati e anche io sono
cresciuta va velocemente quattro
promozioni in sei anni e poi finalmente
arriva la mia bambina arriva nastasia
tre mesi a casa poi qualcosa nello
stomaco comincia a girare sentivo il
bisogno di tornare nel mio habitat
naturale
l'ufficio quindi con la scusa di dare il
cambio ai colleghi durante le vacanze di
natale eccomi guerriera con mamma
bambina carrozzina al seguito il 27 di
dicembre è stato un rientro bello
frizzante perché di lì a poco neanche un
mese è arrivata una nuova promozione un
nuovo incarico
e allora lì mi sono trovata in cima alla
piramide organizzativa che fare
avevo lavorato su quello stesso progetto
per i sette anni precedenti e quindi
quel giro nello stomaco si era
trasformato in un pugno cosa c'era che
non andava c'era che adesso la barca la
guidavo io mi sono sentita completamente
inadeguata incompetente ho avuto
tantissima paura ho sentito il giudizio
il fiato del giudizio degli altri sul
mio collo e lo ho temuto tantissimo per
sopravvivere quindi ho adottato un
approccio efficacissimo velocità
sopravvivenza sopravvivenza velocità
dritti alla meta col salto agli ostacoli
le cose che non ero capace di fare le
faceva ugualmente senza lasciarle fare
agli altri che sapevano peraltro farle
molto meglio di me perché il mio
obiettivo erano i risultati aziendali
l'essere riconosciuta come una persona
valida e degna di quel posto e poi c'era
il mio territorio io volevo portare bene
alla mia gente volevo far crescere
l'economia di quel posto per cui mi sono
ritrovati una situazione veramente
veramente complicata a casa come in
ufficio tutti presi dal ticchettio
dell'orologio e non si dava tempo
neanche neanche di di raccogliere le
persone o aiutare le persone che erano
inciampati in ostacoli che non erano
riusciti a superare poi torno dicevo poi
torno e a volte invece poi non tornavo e
con gli obiettivi di famiglia anche lì a
tutto gas
machiavelli disse una volta il fine
giustifica i mezzi e se avessimo giocato
una partita sarebbe finita così daniela
machiavelli 1 a 0 un giorno stavo
allattando la mia piccola bambina e il
telefono mentre stavo mandando una mail
e cade direttamente sulla testa dopo un
attimo di preoccupazione
mi sarei dovuta fermare quello poteva
essere un segnale e dopo 15 anni lo
riconosco allora ho solo pensato
speriamo che la mia e non sia partita
che era ancora in bozza
sono passati sei anni
anni di grandi soddisfazioni di corse di
grandi gioie professionali ma anche di
irte salite e di qualche dolore perché
altri bambini non ne arrivavano e poi è
arrivato michelangelo l'estate in cui è
nato michelangelo che ho passato in
maternità è stata una bella estate calma
tranquilla con i bambini che giocavano
dormivano sotto un albero o al mare
vivevamo in una casa ristrutturata
proprio di fresco in quel momento
ovviamente facendo dannare muratori
amici architetto quasi fino a perdere
tutto quanto
e poi ad agosto di nuovo quel bollore
allo stomaco e torno in ufficio per dare
di nuovo il cambio ai colleghi che
andavano in vacanza e cosa ho trovato
una sorpresa
meravigliosa un team cresciuto
splendidamente voluto rafforzato dall
unicità delle persone che lo componevano
e non mi dimenticherò mai il giorno in
cui mi dissero dani mentre eri via
abbiamo fatto così cosa ne dici funziona
funziona avrei voluto dire io è invece
sono rimasta così stordita che non mi
sono neanche quella volta affermata
festeggiare ea celebrare
concedendomi il diritto alla parola stop
e loro a prendersi i propri spazi
però qualcosa stava già cambiando c'era
di nuovo qualcosa che si muoveva in me è
più e più volte erano più le volte che
la mia anima agitava il cartellino rosso
se da un lato i risultati sul lavoro i
risultati economici avevano una barra
dritta così quelli sul clima aziendale
andavano giù così e in casa la cosa che
più frequentemente mi sentivo dire era
quel caratteraccio dani mettilo a bada
che non sei mica in ufficio mi ci sono
voluti molti anni per elaborare e per
fare un percorso che però allora sentivo
proprio di non poter più rimandare
ma perché corriamo
corriamo per non annoiarci
corriamo perché abbiamo paura e ci
nascondiamo dietro la corsa per
nascondere anche i nostri limiti
corriamo perché siamo dannatamente
competitivi e se arriviamo secondi ci
rode
corriamo perché se gli altri corrono
abbiamo paura a nostra volta di rimanere
soli
corriamo perché confondiamo l'urgenza
con la nostra impazienza e ci
dimentichiamo dell'importanza delle cose
poi corriamo perché ci hanno detto che
prima o poi dobbiamo morire quindi
meglio farne un po di cose brega che la
signora in nero arrivi e corriamo perché
la corsa diventa la nostra meravigliosa
coperta di linus c'è una frase molto
bella che linus dice a charlie brown la
mia coperta è quel metro scarso di
flanella che mi separa dall'esaurimento
nervoso
ma quali sono i rischi di lunga corsa di
una corsa folle beh sicuramente ci sono
quelli fisici malattie gastriche
cardiovascolari disturbi
dell'alimentazione e poi ci sono quelli
emotivi
non siamo più in grado di concentrarci
sulle cose la soglia d'attenzione crolla
miseramente il nostro focus svanisce c'è
una ricerca molto importante che dice
che l'attenzione dell'uomo oggi
inferiore a quella del pesce rosso il
che fa molto onore al pesce rosso
confondiamo e non siamo più in grado di
stabilire cosa è giusto e cosa è
sbagliato cose belle cose brutto cosa
importante cosa non lo è inevitabile se
prendiamo decisioni sbagliate e poi non
siamo più in grado di sognare di
emozionarci e anche di amare e perdiamo
gli altri intorno a noi ma forse siamo
noi che li abbiamo lasciati da soli
abbiamo perso anche la capacità di
ridere però ricordiamoci che ridere è un
condensato di forze in un vecchio tanto
sentito dire che ridere è come correre
militare fare sesso contemporaneamente
ma allora
corriamo
o scappiamo
e un'altra domanda
è tutto proprio così brutto non c'è
niente di buono nella corsa ci sono
molte cose buone perché corriamo qua
quando corriamo a cui ha una grande
quantità di energia ci sentiamo più
forti siamo galvanizzati
dalla e crescere la nostra autostima e
ci mettiamo via anche un po di quel
senso di onnipotenza che poi ci servirà
magari in futuro quando corriamo
viviamo gli stessi attimi che si vivono
quando siamo felici ea me è sempre
capitato così
e poi c'è un ormone magico che si
sviluppa anche nei momenti di stress
positivo è il sito cina che è un ormone
che serve a tantissime cose e serve
anche a contrastare le malattie
cardiovascolari ad aumentare la
resilienza allo stress per cui la
chimica che sta dietro la corsa può
rivelare insomma
sorprese cose meravigliose
lo stress positivo quindi può essere
potenziante se viene vissuto come un
alleato e non come un nemico e
soprattutto se non diventa cronico ecco
il nostro problema che molto spesso
trash trasformiamo le cose in croniche
e alla fine la risposta giusta tra cosa
dobbiamo fare
dipende
non c'è vento favorevole per il marinaio
che non sa dove andare disse seneca
noi dobbiamo sapere dove andare e perché
vogliamo andare in un posto piuttosto
che in un altro
quali sono gli strumenti di cui abbiamo
bisogno per raggiungere quel posto
incluso il ritmo il piede sul freno
sull'acceleratore ce l'abbiamo noi nelle
nostre mani non la società le
aspettative che gli altri hanno per noi
oppure le nostre paure perché nella vita
a volte bisogna correre per rilasciare
energia o per accumulare energia per
recuperare un ritardo o magari mettervi
a un po di vantaggio per tendere una
mano a qualcuno o per chiedere aiuto
oggi cammino
cammino perché vedo di rita la strada
davanti a me e quando c'è un bel
rettilineo una profonda discesa mi
diverto anche a correre cammino perché
mi sono fatto un sacco di amici
camminando e cammino perché quando lo
faccio in compagnia mi faccio anche due
chiacchiere perché la voglia di fare due
cose 34 contemporaneamente non mi è
ancora passata cammino perché durante il
cammino possa raccogliere tantissime
informazioni metterle via quando sono
arrivati in fondo al mio viaggio avrò
imparato così tanto che poi non c'è un
solo viaggio camminando ci sono infiniti
viaggi
cammino perché mi riposo e quando poi
dovrò fare la volata sarò più
performante cammino perché mi prendo
cura di me e degli altri e soprattutto
cammino perché così qualcun altro può
allenarsi a correre
sono nata in ritardo per questo sempre
corso ma ho imparato moltissimo ad amare
la bellezza della lentezza
[Musica]
sì